the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu so I'm a Schultz and this is
nick this cheryl and we work on the back
indicator and to start off let's see
short hands who here knows how to play
back in ok a few so to give you an idea
of how it works it involves both skill
and luck and it's a two-player game and
the object is to move all your pieces
past your opponent's pieces and off the
board so White's trying to move his
pieces this way down and across and
browns trying to move his pieces the
other way and you move by rolling the
dice some important rules or that you
cannot land on a point on which your
opponent has two or more pieces and if
your opponent only has a single piece
there you can land on it and send it
back to the beginning so the goals of
this project can we start off where
first of all to implement the rules of
backgammon get the game going and that
took a good amount of work the next we
want to create or find the function that
evaluates or says how good a given board
is and then we want to be able to look
into the future in in order to better
determine what move to choose now and
this is the part of the program that we
parallelized and finally our last goal
was to try to teach the player teach the
player how to improve by suggesting why
one move might be better than another in
English so the start with the two basic
kinds of board evaluation are just a
static evaluator and an oral net and the
static value our static evaluator works
by looking at features of the board and
creating
score based on that feature and then
multiplying it by weight based on how
important that feature is and summing
them up so a program like this was
created by Hans Berliner at CMU in 1979
and it was actually the first program to
beat a ruling world champion and they
say the program when and we're only
important features was it adjusted the
weights as the game went on because
certain features became less important
as the game progressed and other
features became more important so the
next approach the appeal of use is
training neural nets to determine how
good a board is and these have been
really successful they work by basically
playing hundreds of thousands if not
millions of games against itself and so
it improves this way and after about a
million and a half games it reaches its
maximum performance and one such a value
board evaluator is Pavel which was
released by Jerry tesoro in 1993 and
this is the evaluation function that we
use for our program select we lost
network connection this is the
evaluation function that we use for our
program and he sort of releases as
benchmark evaluator so that other people
in the development commute community
could have something to compare their
evaluate errs against and it plays a
intermediate level if not a pretty
strong level so our next goal was to
implement the search that looks into the
future in order to help choose the best
move now one of the challenges of this
is that the branching factor is so large
because you don't know what the dice
rolls are going to be in the future and
like in checkers the brant the branching
factor is 10 in chess is 35 to 40 but in
backgammon for a turn it's around 400
another challenge that we faced in the
search what was that the pub eval
function that we use is not zero sum so
that produce some challenges that you'll
see and also there's the question of
whether surfing searching
deeper actually does produce better play
and most papers say that the board
evaluator is more important than the
searching deeper but they do say that
searching into the future doesn't prove
play and especially when you're already
at a pretty high level of play where
everyone's near the same and playing
really well a slight perform a slight
increase in performance could make a big
difference so here's an illustration of
the search tree to give you a better
idea of how it works so say it sexist
turn there might be 20 or so moves that
he can commit now these are series of
moves so you roll the two dice and if
their doubles you get four moves certain
turns you may not be able to move at all
so you might not have any moves so that
really varies so after those 20 moves
owes the other player Oh is going to
roll and there's 21 different
denominations he can have and then for
each of those there's about 20 moves and
then it's X's roll and once again he has
21 days combinations and then X's move
so this is looking to moves into the
future so the idea is to build this
search tree and then at this point we're
already up to 3.5 million boards and so
you have all these leaf nodes that
represent your boards and you're going
to evaluate them with your evaluation
function to determine how good they are
since it's not 0 psalm you have to
evaluate it for both player and these
both these values need to get passed up
as you're going to move back up the tree
to determine the best move so you start
at the bottom and you say that since the
texts move he's going to choose the best
possible move given that role and then
in order to move up further and
calculate the value for the parent node
you say it's equal to the probability of
the dice roll for the child no
of times the value that's stored in that
child node and then you keep doing this
in repeating this Oh picks his best move
and sort of sums the expected value and
then you get back up to the top and X
picks his best move so now i'm going to
hand it over to Mike who's going to talk
about the part of the clue that we
paralyze there's a question you get
question can you use alpha beta pruning
you know about alpha beta pruning oh
yeah people have used that and just like
it being searched narrow it down
typically go down to the square root of
n so you wouldn't have a twenty
branching factor rather than the four
hundred it seems like a real payoff if
you can make it work here I don't know
yeah there's some reason backgammon why
it's hard um well we actually didn't get
to that point where I just spent a lot
of time just implementing rules the game
alright so uh so the first thing we
looked at and said this would be perfect
for parallel parallelizing is just the
brute force evaluation of those you know
million of boards that you get down to
at the end which if you want to run
through on one processor just takes a
while so we decided to just generally
evaluation of a board regardless of its
state takes the same amount of time so
we just had to split the number evenly
between a SPU's we had to keep it around
a multiple of four just to get the DMA
calls to line up nicely with the floats
that we were returning and things like
that so if you're evaluating million
boards which was our a million was our
number for our benchmarks that we did
each SPU has about 170,000 to handle and
it clearly can't take all those over at
once so each SPU knows where it's
supposed to start how many is supposed
to do and it knows how much it can pull
over so it doesn t make all the point as
much as it can process processes those
evaluates them returns them and gets the
next bunch so that is what we're we're
able to implement there's also a great
opportunity for double buffering there
for pulling them in as it's actually
evaluating the previous ones so that
would be actually a pretty easy step to
do next but each of those six ship
roughly finish at the same time and then
get back to the PPU to to evaluate to
run up that tree and another opportunity
to make it a bit quicker which we didn't
quite get to would be Simba is in the
evaluation function so we could do four
boards at once with the vector
intrinsics instead of just one so the
performance that we got when looking at
you know the number of SP is we were
using was actually roughly proportional
to the number of SPS we were using it's
actually 18.1 eight at the top there so
when using two instead of one we got
just about half when using three
instead of one we got just about a third
if you just look at this speed up graph
it's pretty much one to one from from
the number SPS we were using to the
amount of time it took so it was a
pretty efficient algorithm for splitting
those up and pulling them back together
I'll give you a brief demo I'll show you
quickly how it looks a mite did Fletcher
network nice a little bit
so we used on just an X Windows setup to
display our very using
so I'm just going to play a couple
rounds of the display let's say you can
sit up here so you can see the computer
just took a couple moves there but
basically what we get here is a printout
of a text representation of the board
and then it's my turn I rolled a 6 92 it
shows here I just don't evaluation says
this is what the best move pronto would
be for me at this point in the ideal
tutoring situation we don't select the
user like what they thought was the best
amend tell him why not but right now
with the time we has how we did it so
mad lists all the legal possible moves
you could make so say I want to move
from point 62.4 it was my piece up there
and I had from eight to two for example
the computer makes its couple so that's
the general idea you can run the
computer against itself as many times
just to test different evaluation
functions against each other you also do
it without the animation on the GUI so
that runs a little I quicker but that's
the general idea just to wrap up that's
believe the way we went about this
basically was we just got to cut
sequential code working on just the pp
you've got the rules of the game worked
out all the weird conditionals and
things that can happen in backgammon and
we faked fix out our bugs and our memory
leaks and things like that we just
shelled out the parallel code and got
that working on the PPU then on one spu
and then on six so this is a pretty
clean process of doing and we ran to a
few walls we aren't really backgammon
experts or even intermediate players so
it's kind of new thing for us to make
sure we had the rules right and we
weren't doing stupid things here and
there
but also managing the search tree was a
big deal and that looking at what what
the program has to do in right in the
game that's the next thing we want to
tackle as far as parallel parallelizing
goes it takes a while and it's pretty
tough so we ran into some memory
management issues with how we're
representing our boards we're able to
pack them down into I think 24 bite
structure point by its structure to be
able to pass some water the SPU's at one
time but so I missed the beginning your
question cuz it was on speakerphone
looking into the future yet so we we
built the code for creating head tray
and evaluating the leaf nodes we didn't
quite have time to finish up okay we
created the code for constructing the
tree and evaluating the leak notes we
haven't quite had time to finish up
moving back up the tree so at this point
we're not looking ahead more than just
the moves for now for like one move
ahead so but we got the parallel code
working for actually evaluating the
boards it shouldn't be too hard to 16
metric to extend that to move back up
the tree and see what the best movies
now yeah so that's that's basically it
as far as the robots we can work so just
some future future ideas um one of the
big ones is for training the evaluation
functions using neural nets that takes a
lot of time for to play hundreds of
thousands millions of games so one of
the ideas is to parallel why's that to
help speed that up and I think we're
about out of time so I closed it are
there any questions I'm just curious you
said looking find in the future it
doesn't necessarily help as much as the
evaluation function does that mean that
I'm AI backgammon is I mean how
computationally intensive is a good
player I mean is it is it a
computationally intensive problem or I
mean do you even I mean would you
benefit from the parallelism in a
practical setting well just looking at
how long it takes to go through those
playing boards like if you're playing a
computer you don't wait 18 seconds for
them that's the time scale of the
absolute if you just ran on a university
like 20 seconds can everything yeah you
doing a million boards about and also if
you're on the level of you know
competing against really good
competitors like just having a deep
surgery to get that much more edge it
would make a difference in that
situation
great